[Musique]
elle s'est lancée dans la bataille des
législatives au dernier moment mais elle
maîtrise parfaitement les codes de la
politique pour l'avoir observée pendant
longtemps à savoir faire précieux
qu'elle a mis au service de Marine Le
Pen son ami de 25 ans
[Musique]
bonjour Caroline Parmentier bonjour
Clément alors en 2018 Marine Le Pen est
venue vous chercher pour vous embaucher
en quelque sorte vous étiez journaliste
à l'époque et vous a demandé de vous
occuper des relations presse du parti et
surtout de ces relations presse à elle
mais votre rôle ne s'est pas limité à
cela pendant 5 ans vous avez aussi fait
un gros travail sur son image et ça
s'est traduit notamment par un nouveau
genre de vidéo posté par Marine Le Pen
sur les réseaux sociaux on regarde
tranquille
mon arbre les sorts
[Musique]
alors la vidéo qu'on vient de voir avec
le chat de Marine Le Pen coincé dans le
sapin de Noël et là quand même fait 4
millions 400 000 vues sur TikTok il y a
rien de politique là-dedans ça fait
quand même partie de la politique selon
vous oui bien sûr bien sûr j'ai toujours
trouvé que j'avais envie que les
Français connaissent Marine Le Pen comme
moi je la connaissais c'est à dire
Rians chantant ayant trois enfants il y
a beaucoup de choses dans sa vie que les
Français ne connaissent pas du tout ils
la voient finalement un peu comme une
femme derrière un pupitre lors des
meetings leur des plateaux télévisés
mais je voulais qu'il se rende compte de
qui elle était et ça a été un peu tout
l'enjeu de cette campagne de la
présidentielle 2022 que les journalistes
d'abord que les photographes ensuite que
les Français
sachent que Marine Le Pen réellement
parce que il y a eu cet aspect là sur
les réseaux sociaux mais il y a pas eu
que cela dans le même registre si on
peut dire pendant la présidentielle on a
vu Marine Le Pen parler donc de ses
chats de sa colocataire face à Karine Le
Marchand on l'a vu évoquer la rupture
avec son père dans une émission face à
Cyril Hanouna face à Baba on l'a vu
aussi se prêter à une interview avec
Magali Berdah sur sur Youtube on a
longtemps parlé de des diabolisation du
rassemblement national et il fallait des
diaboliser Marine Le Pen ou en tout cas
la normalisée c'est Marine Le Pen c'est
aussi une française comme vous et moi
voilà vraiment c'est quelque chose qui
me frappe quand je quand je suis avec
elle c'est quelqu'un de simple marine
qui a un contact direct avec les gens
qui a de l'empathie
les habitants de sa circonscription du
Pas-de-Calais le savent bien d'ailleurs
il était important en effet que les
Français la voient comme ça pour moi
alors on connaît tous le slogan Paris
Match le poids des mots le choc des
photos ça pourrait presque être votre
devise à vous aussi pour ce qui est du
choc des photos vous êtes tout de suite
insurgé contre les photos qui étaient
choisies par certains journaux pour
illustrer leurs articles consacrés à
Marine Le Pen
êtes-vous plaisait pas ça veut dire quoi
c'est à dire que être traduisait un
parti pris politique selon vous c'est je
trouve que ce n'était pas des photos
honnêtes quand je suis arrivée au
rassemblement national en 2018 comme
vous l'avez dit après que Marie de met
débauché et bien les photos les on avait
coutume de voir des photos de marine où
elle était moche où elle était parfois
affreuse prise par en dessous elle
faisait peur et je pense que l'idée
c'était ça d'ailleurs c'était de dire oh
là là mais parce que vous savez comme
moi que la plupart des gens quand même
elle regarde la photo lise le titre de
l'article et puis c'est tout parfois
donc j'ai commencé par parler au
photographe à même en leur disant mais
c'est comme ça que vous l'aviez c'est
vraiment vous qui avez pris cette photo
vous rentreriez le soir chez vous en
voyant votre avec une photo comme ça de
votre femme de votre épouse de votre
belle-mère je pense que vous seriez
curieusement reçu et puis j'ai parlé aux
rédactions aussi et j'ai dit aux
rédactions que que c'était plus possible
voilà ça me paraissait pas juste elle
était jolie elle était elle était blonde
elle avait minci elle était je ne
voulais pas apparaissent comme comme sur
ses photos ça pour le choc des photos et
alors pour le poids des mots vous avez
décidé de reprendre systématiquement les
journalistes qui qualifient le RN de
parties d'extrême droite c'est une
bataille sémantique que vous avez
d'ailleurs menée avec un certain succès
mais est-ce que c'est pas une certaine
remise en cause de la liberté de la
presse écoutez il faut être juste il
faut être honnête aussi le rassemblement
national et Marine Le Pen ne
correspondent en aucun cas à l'extrême
droite à la qualification d'extrême
droite on connaît la définition des
traits droites anti parlementarisme
contestation des résultats électoraux
enfin voilà tout ça c'est absolument pas
le rassemblement national et j'ai trouvé
que c'était une injustice oui j'en ai
beaucoup parlé clafp notamment je
trouvais que c'était une injustice c'est
un combat que Jean-Marie Le Pen avait
lui aussi mené en son temps un bien
avant vous au point que en 1996 la
justice a estimé que l'emploi du
qualificatif d'extrême droite par les
journaux à l'époque c'était Libération
et Le Monde relevé de la liberté
d'opinion d'analyse et de changement
d'un journal d'ailleurs ils ont ils ont
continué à le faire encore une fois vous
même vous moi mon idée vous avez
pratiqué une forme de journaliste
engagée on va en parler vous auriez
accepté que un parti politique vous
impose une façon précise de le qualifier
non mais j'aurais écouté ce qu'il avait
à me dire j'aurais écouté ce qu'elle
vient à me dire mon idée n'était pas de
les persuader de les obliger mais d'en
discuter avec eux et de leur montrer qui
m'explique pourquoi ça n'était plus
justifié selon moi ça a été plus
justifié et lorsque j'étais journaliste
j'aurais été ravi de parler avec un
homme politique de ça ça voilà ça ou
avec une attachée de presse si je pense
que le ça fait partie du métier aussi de
de discuter et de de d'échanger sur ces
vues voilà alors si je dis vous avez
travaillé pour un journal d'extrême
droite vous allez me reprendre
je
réduisais oui oui cet appellation pour
mon journal aussi bon alors vous avez
vous avez fait toute votre carrière au
journal présent c'était le journal que
lisez vos parents je crois qu'il voter
sur le front national ils étaient juste
sympathisants ou est-ce qu'ils avaient
une forme d'engagement politique
et donc vous êtes arrivés au journal
présent comme stagiaire je crois que
vous aviez 21 ans et vous êtes restés 31
ans c'est un journal qui était sur une
ligne proche des milieux catholiques
traditionnels listes ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que pour vous le
journaliste devait forcément traduire
une forme d'engagement il fallait
défendre des idées des valeurs je pense
que oui la journaliste d'opinion
m'intéressait à l'époque et j'ai tout de
suite vu l'occasion aussi comme quoi il
y a quand même un lien j'ai tout de
suite vu l'occasion de suivre le Front
National et le rassemblement national et
ça a été ma fonction en effet d'aller
dans tous les meetings dans toutes de
les interviewer dans toutes les
conférences de presse le plus possible
dans la mesure des moyens de ce petit
journal qui en avait pas beaucoup dans
les voyages si on pouvait et c'est comme
ça d'ailleurs que j'ai rencontré Marine
Le Pen et alors qu'est-ce que je ne
connaissais pas personnellement on va
évoquer dans un instant mais quels sont
vos idées vos valeurs que vous avez
voulu défendre à travers ce journaliste
d'opinion comme vous dites alors quand
j'étais journaliste encore une fois je
n'écrivais pas que sur la politique
j'écrivais également je faisais des
chroniques cinéma j'en ai fait beaucoup
à une époque j'allais au cinéma tous les
jours dans ma jeunesse j'ai j'écrivais
également sur la police et effectivement
sur sur le rassemblement national pour
le coup les idées de Marine Le Pen je me
suis tout de suite reconnue dans les
idées de Marine Le Pen parce qu'elle
défendait elle aimait la France et elle
aimait les Français voilà et pour moi
l'engagement politique c'est celui-là
c'est de défendre la France et les
Français loin des grandes envolées ou
des des joues de verbales ou des
histoires des leçons d'histoire à la
sauvette je pense que les Français
attendent aujourd'hui des hommes
politiques qu'il les défendent dans leur
quotidien et qu'ils améliorent leur vie
quotidienne voilà donc c'est votre
travail de journaliste qui vous a permis
de rencontrer Marine Le Pen c'était à la
fin des années 90 à l'occasion de ce
qu'on appelait la fête bébé air à
l'époque le blanc rouge tous les ans la
fête du du Front national qu'est-ce qui
vous a rapproché toutes les deux je l'ai
tout de suite trouvé sympathique drôle
grande gueule fine dans cette analyse
politique on avait deux ans d'écart
d'âge finalement ce qui n'est pas
beaucoup on était toutes les deux
divorcés on avait toutes les deux trois
enfants qui avaient les mêmes âges ce
sont des choses qui qui font qu'on peut
qu'on puisse on peut se reconnaître
enfin moi je peux me reconnaître en elle
elle avait la gentillesse de me dire
qu'elle a qu'elle m'avait suivi dans
certains de mes articles et puis moi
j'avais énormément suivi bien sûr en
2011 quand elle est arrivée à la tête du
parti
rassemblement national il y a eu une
scission dans mon journal dans mon petit
journal il y a une session entre ceux
qui voulaient rester proche de
Jean-Marie Le Pen qui trouvait que
Marine n'était pas l'avenir qu'elle
n'incarnait pas ce qu'il fallait et moi
qui voulait que ce soit marine et on
s'est on s'est bien battus
ça a été assez ardu et je suis devenu
rédactrice en chef voilà ça
effectivement ça correspond à une
certaine réalité mais
maintenant vos années de journalistes
mais vous avez aussi parfois sembler
être politiquement plus proche d'Eric
Zemmour ou de Marion maréchal que qui
n'existait pas à l'époque je précise
enfin ou très peu oui que de Marine Le
Pen vous l'avez critiqué notamment quand
elle a écarté son père de
l'organigramme du parti très exactement
avez-vous avez-vous vraiment l'article
sous les yeux pas sous les yeux non je
ne l'ai pas critiqué ça c'est un des
journalistes qu'on dit ça mais il m'est
arrivé d'autrefois de la critiquer
sûrement mais sur ce point précis j'ai
dit qu'elle n'avait pas le choix que
c'était terrible que c'était
horriblement pénible pour une fille pour
nous tous qui avions beaucoup de respect
pour Jean-Marie Le Pen mais qu'elle
n'avait pas le choix qu'elle n'avait pas
le choix parce que sinon ce serait sans
fin est-ce que c'est pas l'amitié plus
encore que la politique qui vous a
poussé à vous engager aux côtés de
Marine Le Pen alors quand elle m'a
demandé de travailler pour elle j'ai été
prise de de d'une certaine angoisse je
parce que je dis pas mon métier
finalement d'être attaché de presse
j'avais peur de faire des erreurs
j'avais peur de voilà mais
certes c'est par amitié pour elle que je
suis venu mais par passion aussi de ce
qu'elle être cette formidable aventure
et ça l'a été d'ailleurs et ça continue
de l'être cette formidable aventure
politique parce que travailler auprès de
Marine Le Pen à la présidentielle c'est
quelque chose d'exceptionnel voilà je
souhaite à tout le monde de vivre cette
aventure là votre candidature au
législatives à ses fêtes tardivement
après le second tour de la
présidentielle qu'est-ce qui vous a
convaincu de franchir le pas de passer
de l'autre côté du miroir devenir une
femme politique alors je vais encore
vous répondre le fait d'avoir suivi
marine j'ai beaucoup suivi marine dans
le Pas-de-Calais dans sa circonscription
comme vous le savez elle était députée
de la circonscription du Pas-de-Calais
elle a elle a été je voyais ce que les
gens lui disaient je l'ai suivi mais
peut-être 10 fois 12 fois dans le
Pas-de-Calais dans le cadre de mon
métier d'attacher de presse je voyais ce
que les gens avaient à lui dire risque
que les habitants du Pas-de-Calais lui
disaient je voyais ce qu'elle leur
répondait et je me suis dit que moi je
pouvais leur apporter quelque chose
voilà je pouvais travailler pour eux et
que je serai une députée qui essaierai
de tenir ses promesses et qui voilà et
qui les encore une fois qui les aiderait
dans leur vie quotidienne allez on va
finir par un quiz alors un quiz un peu
différent de d'habitude un quiz spécial
chti pourquoi et parce que vous avez été
investi au législatif vous l'avez dit
dans dans le Pas-de-Calais mais vos
attaches si on peut dire ils étaient
plutôt en région parisienne alors l'idée
c'est de voir si vous êtes bien
acclimaté à votre nouvelle région
on commence on commence par une
spécialité locale à vous de la
reconnaître de quoi s'agit-il oui bien
sûr le patch oui alors le punch là vous
avez
abrégé le nom c'est le poche belge
exactement mais habitudes ondulepot
trois viandes en gelées lapin porc veau
mais ça peut être voilà et avec ça c'est
très bon qu'une salade et c'est
excellent avec des frites au maroilles
un mot à présent si je vous dis wassang
oui alors là vous me posez une colle
aidez-moi on va la voir en images ouais
5 c'est la serpillière en ch'ti bon
c'est un peu piège comme question
on termine par une comptine célèbre dans
la région à vous de la compléter
dorment un petit Quinquin un petit oui
bien sûr le beffroi là je vous
régulièrement le beffroi de Béthune dors
mon petit coin mon petit mignon mon
petit
il y a mon petit mais entre les deux
même petit poussin même gros rojin mon
petit poussin mon gros raisin voilà moi
je traduis parfait donner mais parfait
merci Caroline Parmentier d'être venu
dans la politique et moi c'est moi qui
vous remercie
[Musique]